[موسيقى]
ففي حال نجحت روسيا في الحرب التي تشمها
على اوكرانيا فان موسكو سوف تعيد صياغه
البنيه الامنيه في اوروبا برمتها وقد نشهد
ظهور جدار حديدي جديد ونوشوب حرب بارده
مجددا على اراضي القاره العجوز عندها سوف
تصبح هذه البلدان تحديدا في خطوط الدفاع
الاولى لحلف النيتو لانها تقع على حدود
روسيا كما انها قد تهاجم بلدان اوروبيه
اخرى مثل مولدوفا وجورجيا لضم المزيد من
اراضيها
[موسيقى]
فان ذلك سوف يتطلب تبني موقف متشدد ايضا
من جانب بلدان اوروبا الشرقيه والسبب يعود
الى ان هذه البلدان ذاتها ستصر على انضمام
اوكرانيا الى حلف النيتو لانه السبيل
الوحيد في نظرها كي تحصل اوكرانيا على
ضمانات امنيه لانها لا تعتبر ان ما تقدمه
فرنسا او المانيا او الاتحاد الاوروبي من
ضمانات سوف يكون كفيلا بحمايه سلامه اراضي
وسياده اوكرانيا مستقبلا
[موسيقى]